all right we are now live for another
political theory and practice discussion
and today we're going to be talking
about
michelle foucault and specifically the
you know subject matter of of this
volume power
um i moved this up a day in part because
i've moved the worlds of speculative
fiction
event that i'll be doing next weekend
which was going to be happening today i
moved that
in time to
next saturday in part because i have to
do more
prep work for that so i thought that
this would be a good
thing to
chat about and
discuss with people so
we'll see how many people make it to the
stream i'm going to talk for a bit
and then i will end up
taking questions comments
addressing anything that people want to
bring up so we'll give it a couple
minutes and i'll just tell you a little
bit about the series for everybody who's
maybe new to it or people who are
watching this so i started doing
this political theory and discussion
series as kind of a monthly
streaming thing
a while back and sometimes we talk about
contemporary issues in politics
sometimes we talk about some key things
to to know if we want to do political
theory well
such as you know thinking about the
american scene
and
you know how fragmented into local
governments everything is and that'll
actually come up with with this foucault
stuff when we're talking about power
relations and sometimes we talk about um
key ideas or contributions that have
been made
by particular
um for the most part political
philosophers although you know we could
expand this into other people as well
sociologists you know straight out
political theorists
and this is one of those so we're going
to talk about michelle foucault's
conception of power relations and i
imagine there'll probably be a good bit
of
dispelling
mistaken viewpoints on foucault and his
work and his ideas and contributions
but we'll get into that as as time goes
on so mark is here uh glad to see you
anybody else if you want to chime in say
where you're
watching from or stuff like that i
always get a kick out of that mark is is
watching from south africa so it's kind
of late
there it's noon here in milwaukee
downtown
um and could be anything depending on
where you are all over the world so
let's let's jump in and let's talk about
michelle foucault and his ideas about
power
so
um
one of the key
one of the key contributions is
adding a different term to our
vocabulary
instead of just talking about power
he talks about power relations
and we're going to get into that
are you going to touch on biopower
obviously we'll touch on biopower but
biopower is very overrated and not as
not as big of a deal as people make it
out to be i'll i'll pull the curtain
back on that one
um so
i'm going to start actually with a few
bits of advice
i think there's a lot of
misunderstandings of foucault and the
relevance of his ideas and what the the
content of the ideas are
and about his basic approach and you
know
living in this internet age there are
some amazing opportunities that it puts
in our lap
um you know for example being able to do
this right here right now
but there's also a tendency to create
superficial easy
takes and understandings you know if you
think about
what it takes to understand a thinker
like you know for example if you want to
understand
um
anselm of canterbury
you got to actually read the book you
got to read his works and you got to do
it multiple times and you can't just
rely on you know what spark notes or
stanford encyclopedia philosophy or
internet encyclopedia philosophy or pick
whatever sites or whatever memes or you
know whatever uh secondary lit happens
to say sooner or later you actually have
to like do the work of going to the
primary texts and with foucault this is
really really important
because you know he's become a popular
philosopher in a way so the same way
that like hegel has the same way that
like spinoza has
where there's a lot of circulation of
of memes not just in the terms of the
internet memes but like richard dawkins
you know original notion of meme um
sort of clusters of ideas like
everything's a prison
well you know i mean foucault actually
in in
various places says no that's not my
view at all
but you know
the everything's a prison thing kind of
outweighs that in terms of its
its cap you know it's
captivating power and it's ease of
transmission compared to the actual text
just like you know um
with any other thinker right we can talk
about that right um
and so
part of what we want to do in in
something like this is get to the get to
the actual meet what does foucault
actually say
so here's a couple pointers
anytime somebody makes a sweeping claim
about foucault's works and ideas um
they're probably full of [ __ ] they
probably don't know what they're talking
about or they have read it and they're
taking some sort of tendentious take
like you know fuco reduces everything to
power if somebody says something like
that you know you know that they don't
know what they're talking about right
and then you should probably
not even bother to engage them just
ignore them and move on to better stuff
because the other cool thing about the
internet is we don't we don't have to
like engage um people and conversations
that are a waste of our time because
there's so many other ones to be
involved in the other thing to realize
about that is if you do read foucault's
work these big sweeping misleading
claims about it like everything's power
everything's a prison you know um
we see fukuoka himself addressing these
i mean he knew that he knew what people
were saying about him
and he deliberately heads off some of
those things at the past
another key point if so foucault is
interested in
um
exploring and and doing so in a rigorous
way a number of
complex
controversial interconnected matters and
these are you know these spill over
these are messy um he's interested in
digging up and interpreting history you
know what was the past how did things
develop
he's also interested in what he calls a
history of the present you know making
sense out of our current situation
and he's interested in thinking about
options for us in light of the things
that he
um you know
figures out the things that he puts in
front of us so we got to be really
really attentive to the limitations
and the qualifications the
yes buts you know involved in in his
work um he doesn't he doesn't lay things
out in a
um
let's say
manifesto style thing he instead he'll
say like okay so
what do we find is happening this
incredibly complex set of changes
and here's the main traits of it that we
can isolate out obviously these are
interconnected with each other don't
expect what i've figured out about say
prisons in america
in the 1800s to immediately transfer on
to prisons
in america in the 2010s or 2020s
obviously he didn't live past the 80s
but he could have said something like
that right
um
so
that's that's another thing and the
other thing that i want to say is um
you know
we we also want to avoid a kind of hero
worship and um
really not just with foucault but any
any thinker who we're involved with
right we don't have to expect that
they've got
everything right
um or
you know we don't we also don't have to
like go to the oh postmodernism is bad
or pick whatever else the conservatives
are against and have the terrible takes
that people like james lindsay and
jordan peterson and all them you know
spout out right um that sort of sort of
[ __ ] there foucault is not a hero or
a villain and really most people in the
history of philosophy
shouldn't be viewed that way we should
say
okay i buy this part i don't buy this
part like for example
when it comes to the history of
sexuality and you read the stuff on
ancient philosophy people who don't know
much ancient philosophy
might buy into foucault's narratives a
little bit too unquestioningly and be
like oh man this is really cool stuff
but if you know your ancient philosophy
there's points where you're like ah come
on guy yeah you don't really expect me
to buy that dude i've actually read
these texts you know uh i see where
you're going with this and you're
telling a cool story but you know i
don't really think that you're really
pushing your your thing your narrative a
little bit too hard on on this case so
you know we we can endorse foucault in
qualified ways um
until we've we've done the you know a
good bit of work um we do have to resist
temptations to you know misread him and
misattribute things
and um
you know so that's that's good to keep
in mind as well so there's already a lot
of questions and comments some of which
are relevant some of which are
irrelevant um to the the topic at hand
uh in in the chat remember this is not
an ama this is focused on
understanding foucault so we'll we'll
talk about that um
and uh i probably won't be addressing
the off-topic uh
question stuff
um so foucault talks about power
throughout his works and
let me say from the start
that you don't have to read all of the
stuff that foucault has written
uh in order to be able to wrap your head
around his his you know basic
ideas and and you know sort of see where
it's going and and develop but you
probably do have to read a good bit in
order to have a good sense of what he's
he's doing otherwise power becomes a
kind of empty reference that can mean
whatever you want it to mean right
and um you know obviously there's
there's a a book that you can get which
doesn't contain everything that he wrote
about the topic but you know you would
think this would be a pretty useful
volume uh you know these these selected
essays and stuff on power but there's
also so this is part of a three volume
set that was uh kind of in grad school
that was coming out uh and then you know
there's there's this one this one's
actually got some some important essays
as well like on some of you are
mentioning biopower well that's where
you can find some of the important
essays in that
so
he talks about power in a lot of places
right and foucault has a number of
different ways in which power and power
relations are going to be
connected up with things uh i would say
that you know very very early on
one of his key insights and it's not an
insight unique to foucault i mean this
is a
insight um from you know that that also
comes from nietzsche and foucault tells
you that you know nietzsche was a very
important
uh
catalyst for people of his generation
that um
truth and
power how power is used how power is
understood how power is imposed are
connected with each other that you don't
have any pure
truth that's just out there waiting for
us to
discover instead we live in a you could
say humanized world in a humanized world
is one
in which there are power relations very
often complex ones that we you know
haven't attended to adequately it takes
power
to
discover to
enunciate to
develop to articulate truth
whether we like it or not
and um
so you know that's that's uh a key
insight and i would say that's there
from the very start right
and then another key thing after we get
you know like
you know past his archaeological period
and we start getting into the straight
out genealogical
work
another key idea is that we we actually
have to like look closely at things
we can't just
generalize
about
power structures or things like that we
need to see what what you know history
actually
reveals to us and that involves um
a lot of work and expense and time and
thinking you can't write you know
discipline and punish or the birth of
the clinic or
any of these other works without doing
an awful lot of research right
and that you know that you can say well
that involves kind of a privileged
position yeah sure totally you know um
that's that's a critique that's been
made against you know uh foucault and
foucaultians for a while but it's kind
of a toothless one because
pretty much everything that we do
requires um something to be subordinated
here it's kind of similar to nietzsche
right not everything is necessarily will
to power
but there's certainly um things that are
you know made to to work for other
things
now when we get to power relations
i actually think that there's there's a
couple um i mean if you only read one
thing
on fuco and on power and this will
actually address some of the questions
that are being asked like
governmentality you know what's that
it's you know
you can read this essay that's in here
called the subject and power that's
that's why i did
a series of uh core concept videos on it
because when i want to have my students
read foucault there's basically two
pieces that i'm i'm having them engage
with i mean i'm not teaching philosophy
majors i'm teaching
art and design
majors at milwaukee institute of art and
design but you know they're very
interested in in continental philosophy
and making sense out of their life so
one of them is the subject in power
and the other one is technologies of the
self which does talk about power right
and so those are those are really
central there's a lot of other really
you know useful essays and stuff like
that where we can get that as well but i
think in a way
um the subject in power the reason i
give it a kind of
privileged position
is because he um he hits on a lot of
these
key ideas and key
themes
and points that he wants to make and
terms
over and over and over again right
um
so anyway
long story short
foucault is going to talk an awful lot
about power there's you know if if you
had to pick some other things i would
say the essay truth in power in this
volume would be very useful and if
you're if you're super interested in bio
power
um you know society must be defended
there's another essay after that and
then the birth of biopower those all
talk about that in in this volume
so let's talk about um
[Music]
actually i'm going to stop here for a
moment so i see people making sweeping
statements about foucault and again i'm
going to remind you that if you make
sweeping statements about foucault like
foucault was a nietzschean
you're wrong and you're screwing
yourself up if you want to
make sure that you don't understand
foucault that's a great way to start you
know saying that foucault was an is this
this this you know
that ain't the way to do it um the way
to do it is to actually
look closely at what foucault is saying
you could say there could be some
influences there but you shouldn't call
them an anything in because that's
that's actually going to lead you off
off base
all right back to talking about the some
of the key ideas so let's talk about
some of the the contributions that he's
articulating not making but articulating
in the subject and power right
um
so you know he tells you
that the goal of his work uh has not
been to analyze the phenomena of power
in order to elaborate the foundations of
this it's been to create a history of
the different modes by which in our
culture human beings are made subjects
and you can say well
why the hell should we care about that
right tell me about power instead well
because power
turns out to be something that is
between subjects
you know a little bit later in the essay
he's going to distinguish between power
relations and relations in which a
person is so dominated
that they're effectively turned into
something like a machine or a circuit or
uh you know they they don't have the
possibility of
you know saying no in some way power is
always something between
subjects right so that's something
really important to
keep in mind and the other thing that we
want to look at here
is well there's several things we want
to look at here but one of the things we
want to look at here
is
what he
talks about
as not being power right so
we we have power relations power
relations
he says
are always
acting not directly upon the person like
if you're torturing somebody that's not
a power relation you know that's that's
something on their
their uh
their body you're treating them as sort
of an object right unless you're trying
to like coerce information out of them
in which case they have some choices to
make
power relations are actions upon the
possible actions of another if i exert
power over you i am not making you do
something in a purely efficient causal
way as if you were a mechanism and in a
certain way you could say that my
relations to this phone even though it's
very anthropomorphized and i have a siri
on it those are all just mechanical
connections right
until until there's something like you
know an actual subject behind the phone
no power relations i can have power
relations with you through the phone
right very complex ones we can have
power relations right here right
but it you have to have actual subjects
in involved in that and not every other
relation is necessarily a
power relation right
um there's lots of other things in our
lives right he talks about relationships
of communication this is something
you're going to see not just in
this essay the subject in power but also
in
the order of things you're going to see
this in
technologies of the self
signs and communication
they can be conflicted with power they
can be
connected up with power in important
ways and they usually are
but communication by itself is not a
power relation for foucault
so this is something i think that is you
know quite interesting to keep in mind
relations of production very often
involve
power relations to make them happen in
certain ways but they are not by
themselves power relations there's
things outside or not necessarily
outside but things that can be
distinguished from power and as a matter
of fact i'm even going to bring up
something that's in technologies of the
self um
so you know their foucault talks about
different kinds of technologies and some
of them are technologies of power
um technologies of the self are
ways in which we actually relate to
ourselves as subjects using power
on ourselves oftentimes within a
tradition a community where there's some
sort of initiation taking somebody's
guidance but
with the idea of bringing about some
sort of good for ourselves which could
be
uh salvation it could be greater control
over our own minds and bodies it could
be you know self-understanding there's
all sorts of things and foucault thinks
that this is what is going on
in a lot of ancient philosophy and
philosophy as a way
of life um so that's that's a
transformative uh
type of power relation
the last thing i'm going to say so i'm
going to get to some of the questions
real soon
power relations are not by themselves
good or bad
foucault doesn't
take the sort of
enlightenment view
that we could ever have a
society that was not like full of power
relations
and any power relation that could be
good in this this particular instance
could be turned to other things
could could go bad you know could be
corrupted likewise um even the things
that we often view is oh that's really
bad tyrannical power
well
you know there was probably some reason
why
some people actually
saw some good in that
you know
so things are not as as cut and dried as
well we need to get away from power
or there's some sort of utopian project
foucault is pretty
uh suspicious about those those sorts of
things and and the things that he
actually you know
in history kind of went you know
took a positive attitude towards usually
turned out to go quite bad you know
think about the iranian revolution for
example
um
but you know foucault wants us to become
educated
in
what we are which is human beings that
is creatures that are in power relations
that antidate us and which we replicate
and which we use and which we sometimes
uh forget about what we're we're doing
and you know he's interested in sort of
like
not diagnosing but
describing and differentiating the
different ways in which these these work
you know and so that's that's what his
his work does there is a one other thing
that i do want to get to later on um and
this is a question sort of about
how applicable is his theorizing which
only went up until the 1980s to
the situations that we find ourselves in
like you know the internet
or
corporate power or
um you know
all sorts of other things that that fit
into you know people want to talk about
the pandemic and biopower and all that
sort of stuff so all right so let's
start at the start um so
here's an interesting question from max
mackin
is there a risk that foucault's idea
power relations can lead to paranoia or
cynical reason as peter slaughter dick
seems to argue and critique of cynical
reason no
there's there isn't a risk that
foucault's idea will lead to that
there's a risk that people
misreading foucault in light of their
own emotional
drives and inadequacies and worries and
all the other stuff they're putting into
the hopper will use foucault to do that
just as much as there's i mean you can
read nietzsche and be like holy [ __ ]
this opens up the world to me or you can
read nietzsche and be like oh this is a
terrible world right
isn't it interesting how we can take the
same thinker
and
find very different responses by people
to it so i mean i don't read foucault
and wind up being paranoid so i mean
i've been reading foucault now for
[Music]
25
longer than that years i mean the first
book that i i got by him was given to me
the order of things and it hasn't turned
me into a paranoiac so you got to ask
with people who make these sorts of
claims what else are they putting into
this
because it's not just foucault's ideas
power relations
that's doing that there's got to be a
lot of other things in the background
that are are um
contributing to that right and we could
say this similarly about um
the crappy takes so somebody mentioned
um stephen hicks uh in his terrible book
on post-modernism
um which was where jordan peterson got
his ideas from um you know and it's sort
of garbage in garbage out
um
but there weren't there were plenty of
other people i mean even i don't think
that habermas
truly understood foucault
uh when he was when he was sort of
lining him up
you know
uh in um
what is it the discourse of of critical
modernity um
now
the difference between a haber moss
misinterpreting foucault
and even even mcintyre i would say
doesn't quite do foucault justice
the difference between those those types
and a stephen hicks or a
um
uh
jordan peterson or whoever is is you
know pretty vast
but you know it's it's uh quite possible
to
to get things wrong right
um
biopower so conor brought biopower up
people are interested in that it's a
it's an interesting term it's not
foucault's not naming something new
and talking about biopower and i think a
lot of people
get sort of sucked into it and they're
like well this is a sexy idea
biopower is just another modality of
power relations right it's power
relations with uh specific kinds of
objects
the the bios the life
um the living thing so
you know you're involved in
in biopower
uh when you
[Music]
take a coronavirus test right and now it
tells you that you need to quarantine
for whatever the the you know strictures
are used to be 14 days now it's like
five days you know who knows what it'll
be tomorrow but somebody's telling you
what to do somebody is exerting actions
on your possible range of actions right
and the testing fits into that and
whether or not you get vaccinated fits
into that and you know it's really quite
this is going to be a little bit of a
rant it's funny to see all the
conspiracy theorists and uh quite
frankly whack jobs out there in red
state america
who who are mirrored by the way in other
places as well but we have it
particularly bad here who think that
like you know they're going to be
microchipped or you know the virus is
taking away their agency and they they
resort to all this weird folk medicine
[ __ ] you know
and i've got relatives who are like that
so you know i'm not just speaking from
like seeing what's what's going on here
in my state but you know from from
experience and engaging with these poor
bastards um
if you think
that being manipulated
by
um
political parties
to be against the coronavirus vaccine
isn't somehow biopower and the
coronavirus vaccine is biopower
then you don't understand biopower you
know um
it's you know there's all sorts of
things going on biopower happens when
insurance companies i remember when this
first started happening when i you know
you get your insurance through your your
uh
job and i remember them
launching these initiatives where like
if you quit smoking your premiums would
go down or you'd get into a weight loss
program your premiums would go down and
if you didn't do that sort of thing
maybe your premiums would go up well
that's biopower i mean this is not this
is not a
mysterious thing
and foucault in his discussions of
biopower he says
governments have been doing this for a
couple hundred years now um and you know
we can see this expand into other areas
as well it doesn't have to necessarily
be a government it could be a
corporation right so there's there's
really nothing mysterious about biopower
it's just um another another type of of
power right
all right so i'm gonna skip the stuff
about jesus and lenin and evangelicals
because i don't see any uh
relevance to the foucault stuff
mark says the sum total of my exposure
to foucault was my in my coursework was
being shown clips of his debate with
chomsky and somebody else brings up the
debate with chomsky as well
which i have not looked at for years and
years and years and years and i don't
really have much to say about it frankly
chomsky i'll say this
is one of those people who i encountered
when i was in grad school and i found
his conceptions of linguistics just you
know
i couldn't take them seriously because
they were they were so
compared to the other stuff that i was
looking at they were so behind the times
and and off base his political stuff was
you know pretty interesting um and and
remains so um
it's it's a very consistent message
right
and you know this is where we could talk
about
we could spin off into foucault and talk
about what what is what are foucault's
politics actually he's getting kicked
around a lot you know all over the place
is he was he a neo-liberal
you know um there's did the cia fund him
uh what's what's going on with this guy
and and one of the things that you want
to understand
in order to make sense out of like
foucault
and not just him but toulouse and
derrida and a lot of these
as they were being called the new
philosophers
back in the the 70s
is that
they were kind of fed up
with um the
failures of both the the you know the
right and the left in european politics
specifically in french politics
and you know they they didn't buy i mean
they they saw all the hypocrisy and
party line [ __ ] and you know the
fact that um within the trade unions
they weren't really working in
democratic ways as they they claim to be
um and i think they react against that
in part and you know foucault wants to
really problematize
uh in the sense of saying hey there's
more here to explore um political
uh
relations and you know political
institutions
and um claims that we're gonna move
towards a
some sort of better future that you know
there's a like a program for and you
know we're still doing this kind of crap
today
you know
um
and so you know
i i think that foucault doesn't have an
easy politics it's not like you could
say well he would i mean he wouldn't
here in america he wouldn't be lining up
with the republicans he would say wow
look at these the [ __ ] nut jobs um
but i don't think he'd be like a
establishment democrat in any respect uh
any i don't know that he'd be um all
that can you know
uh
congenial with the the the harder left
or anything like that so then it was
would he be a radical centrist no
because centrists are mostly you know
there are they're really on the right
anyway is what they demonstrate
themselves to me when they open their
mouths
i mean he would be somebody who'd say
look
individuals
you know they can participate in larger
political structures but they need to
figure out what the hell is actually
going on
how power works
how how you know the relations are
connected with each other
he cautions by the way in that essay in
here subject in power
don't confuse power relations with
with politics or with institutions power
relations are a wider net
and these other things figure within
them you know
all right uh
max says how does fukko and power
relations relate to essentialism totally
depends on what you mean by essentialism
that's that's not a universal term that
you that people can just throw out there
right
uh he seems to from my reading argue
that the medical juridical apparatus
creates identities is he rejecting
identity essentialism i mean if so if
that's what you mean by essentialism
thinking that we have identities we're
all we're all uh essentialists then even
those of us who claim to be
anti-essentialist have some sort of
identity so
that's probably not what what what what
you mean by that right um and identities
you know identities are not just a
substantive but a relational term you
have an identity
in relation to all sorts of stuff i mean
i'm showing my identity as a
lover of budgie right now by wearing
this shirt that i wore back from the gym
after i did my my workout um you know i
think it's
this guy right here who died recently
and you know kind of nostalgic about
that
um
is that identity in the same way as like
the as you're calling at the uh
uh medical juridical apparatus i mean
and we got to be careful with this what
do we mean when we say the medical
juridical apparatus is there some sort
of weird skeleton out there that's an
apparatus no it's going to be things
like uh the hospital that you go to for
your checkups you know and yours may be
very different than mine if you're in in
britain and you're going to you know
national health care service uh funded
stuff that's very different than me
going to freighter health you know
um there isn't a single apparatus out
there that that's doing all this dirty
work
there's all sorts of aparat high and
some of them resemble each other and
some of them don't you know and they're
not all part of one seamless
thing and they give us things that we
can we can call identities i mean are
you just reducible to being a patient i
mean if you get coveted and you're stuck
on a respirator um
you may be right because you you have no
agency anymore um but your family may be
in there pestering the doctor to give
you ivermectin
uh in which case your identity is um you
know lined up with uh
alternative medicine medicine slash
conspiracy theory
people about that and you may not even
have chosen that like you might be the
poor bastard who's got a crazy spouse
who's like we we got to use this stuff
don't use the standard treatment or
something like that and that could be
part of your identity as well right
um
i i think that you know there's lots of
ways in which foucault thinks identity
is created how that connects up with
what you're calling essentialism i don't
really know i mean do you think that we
have like
fixed identities that are our essences
um
if that's what bothers you then then
that's not what foucault is actually
saying um
so i think that this one this one i i
have to punt on right
um
chris foucault was definitely against
sweeping claims as you said this can be
seen not just from the different periods
and changing perspectives but the desire
to want to write anonymously yeah i mean
it's pretty important to
not just for coal lots and lots of
authors right want to be able to
make progress in in their their work i
mean
i'm i'm not somebody with a stature for
co but you know i came into graduate
school and i my intent was to study
philosophy of language so i came in you
know armed with um you know some
pretty good french and some decent
german
and working on latin and and having you
know puttered around a little bit with
mandarin
and you know i was reading stuff in
continental philosophy of language and
an analytic philosophy of language and
then i got into semiotics and then you
know eventually that led me to get
really really interested in darida
and then you know being interested in
darida meant actually like thinking
about some of the people that he wrote
about
and taking them seriously
in ways that continental people weren't
and you know
learning greek and studying plato and
aristotle
much more closely and then to work on my
latin studying medieval thinkers and
pretty soon i'm no longer a philosophy
language guy i'm now a
uh
historian
a philosophy kind of guy slash
philosophy is a way of life guy working
on all sorts of other thinkers
this is kind of normal right
um and so you know so foucault goes
through
what get identified as stages in his
development
um
and you know do they do these stages
really correspond to you know like
here's here's one period here's another
here's another
you know you kind of move into a period
in a whole set of of um little changes
that you that you make but
you know if you think about foucault's
work
um
[Music]
there's a lot of stuff going into it
and there's a lot of
a lot of um
being very careful to like try to pick
apart all the different things and
distinguish them and say what they are i
mean so great example of this right
um in the subject in power
he uh
tells uh here's just one one
good example generally it can be said
there's three types of struggles against
forms of domination against forms of
exploitation that separate individuals
from what they produce or against that
which ties the individual to himself and
submits him to others this way struggles
against subjection against forms of
subjectivity and submission i mean
that's that's a nice distinction right
there and then he goes on immediately
and says
by the way these often like inform each
other and
they're not so easily detanglable right
if you think about working a shitty job
for you know we'll say for the man
making pizzas which is something i've
actually done there's exploitation going
on there's probably some domination
going on and there's probably a little
bit of uh so you know subjection going
on uh until like you know they changed
their
um way of punching in
and now there's like more so you know
you're caught up in some some digital
networks and stuff like that there's
more subjectification
or they start you know they get
interested in like employee training and
morale and now you're being invited to
like tell people what you think about
the shitty pizza parlor that you work in
where you're getting paid you know
pennies uh you know compared to what
what the place is making um you know
these all kind of figure into each other
and if we were doing a fukodian analysis
what we'd want to do is bring to bear
the tools that foucault
provides us with and see whether they
help us make sense out of
the condition that we're in and the
answer might in some cases be no you
know sometimes foucault might not
actually be all that helpful
um
all right
uh mark asked if i'm familiar with
achilles members notion of necropolitics
as a response to foucault's biopolitics
only in the most vague sense i mean i've
sat in on a few conference papers where
people were bringing that up and i don't
know if they were
properly presenting members notion of
necropolitics and and a lot of it was
unfortunately people who were like this
is the the key that answers everything
and
so i don't i didn't get that much out of
it um so i don't have too much to say
about that
uh max how do foucault's theory of power
relations relate to his idea of
governmentality governmentality is a
specific way in which power relations
get structured in terms of um you know
on the one hand states and then all
these like institutions that that figure
into it
and actually this is a good place to
talk about that issue of the state
you know some people have um
uh
you know some people think that foucault
focused too much on
the nation state
um and that you know we should be
looking at other things as other other
ways in which power gets
determined you know
and foucault does say and again this is
in the subject in power
that um the state
has
has historically now a new kind of um
[Music]
centrality right
um and this this actually uh
um
ties into you know governmentality and
disciplinarity and stuff like that
um
so there's two things i'm gonna
read to you here out of this this essay
one one is uh also good because it shows
that he doesn't think everything's a
prison
what is to be understood by the
disciplining of societies in europe
since the 18th century is not
of course
that the individuals who are part of
them become more and more obedient
nor that all societies become like
barracks schools or prisons
rather it is that an increasingly
controlled more rational and economic
process of adjustment has been sought
between productive activities
communication networks and the play of
power relations
that seems pretty right
now is it the same in every place no
it's going to be tighter in some places
looser in other places
but it is being it is it is a sort of
in in general you know where the
trajectory is going
now um
a little bit later on he talks about um
states
uh
where is this right actually i'm going
to read you a third thing a second
um
so this is talking about the his his
discussion of um power relations what
would be proper to a
to a relationship of power
is that it be a mode of action on
actions that is power relations are
rooted deep in the social nexus
not a supplementary structure over and
above society whose radical effacement
one could perhaps dream of
to live in society is in any event to
live in such a way that one can act on
the actions of others a society without
power relations can only be an
abstraction
which be it said in passing makes at all
the politic all the more politically
necessary the analysis of power
relations in a given society
their historical formation the source of
their strength their fragility the
conditions that are necessary to
transform some or to abolish others this
gives you an idea of what what he's up
to right all right so finally here the
state
the third thing i got a little
distracted on the way
he says um
this is backing up a little bit we see
why the the analysis of power relations
within a society cannot be reduced to a
study
of a series of institutions or even to
the study of all those institutions that
would merit the name political power
relations are rooted in the whole
network of the social
that is not to say
that there is a
primary and fundamental
uh principle of power which dominates
the society down to the smallest detail
but based on this possibility of action
on the action of others that is
co-extensive with every social
relationship
various kinds of individual disparity of
objectives of the given application of
power over ourselves or other
data
will define different kinds of power
the forms and the specific situations of
the government of some by others in a
given society are multiple
they are
he goes on to say
superimposed they cross over limit and
in some cases a null reinforce one
another then it goes on it is certain
that in contemporary societies
the state is not simply one of the forms
of specific situations of the exercise
of power even if it is the most
important
but that in a certain way all other
forms of power relation must refer to it
so there's a centrality there to the
state right and we have to be careful
about taking what a uh french
intellectual says which is gonna be
driven you know in part by the
absolutely centralized french state
about other states but i think he's
generally right
so he goes on and he says
this is not because they power relations
are derived from it rather it is because
power relations have come more and more
under
state control although the estate
control has not taken the same form in
pedagogical juridical economic or family
systems
using the restricted meaning of the word
government
one could say that power relations have
become progressively
governmentalized that is to say
elaborated rationalized and centralized
in the form of or under the auspices of
state institutions
now you could say okay well that's cool
maybe that was the case in you know 1980
um what about today when privatization
has been you know
taken to be such a important thing in
like in america
and in in britain to some degree
um well those are still
you know you when you privatize
something you are bringing in market
forces and companies that are doing
things but they're still connected with
the state the state is paying them right
uh the state is managing them there are
als there are still all sorts of
connections with the state
and the fact that sometimes corporations
can act as if they're their own little
governments
doesn't really change what foco is
talking about i mean the rise of of big
tech
um can um
uh you know give us things that that
appear to us to be like oh wow you know
look at this you know apple has more
revenue than some gdp well [ __ ] that was
the case back in the 50s with some of
the multinationals
it's not a radically
new idea and and maybe we want to expand
beyond just just the state but this i
think the state really does remain
pretty central even if it's pretty
ineffective and dysfunctional a lot of
the time so all right let me uh
see where where else people were writing
um
let's see
a lot of individual experience about
getting the jab blah blah blah blah blah
from melahan philosophers corner medical
fascism
you know
this probably isn't the place to go on
your soapbox about that sort of thing
uh max what are the details of
foucault's genealogical method and how
does one use this method well
you want to see how it's used read
foucault and you'll see him using it
and you know
part of what you do so let's back up a
bit um when we talk about genealogical
method we're not talking about
ancestry.com or stuff like that we're
talking about tracing phenomena that
some people want to say oh they have
this this nice simple origin that we can
make sense of think about like
evolutionary biology people who are very
naive uh and are non-genealogical in
this respect for the most part and when
and when they stop being that they often
like shift out of evolutionary biology
or psychology
think about nietzsche's genealogy of
morals how does he begin it he says
these english psychologists
they want to say the origin of good is
in what was useful for the group how the
hell would they know that
we need to actually like see
what we've got in history
now we don't have an aw you know we
can't like go back to cavemen and stuff
like that
but we can like look at language
nietzsche says foucault says well hell
we don't have to just look at language
we can look at the records that are
there in institutions and see what
people are actually saying this is what
the genealogical method does
it sifts through a significant amount of
information
and then it says all right
how did things develop
and it doesn't say okay because
something developed from this it's
always going to be this way again
reading nietzsche's genealogy could be
very helpful for that read essay to his
discussion of punishment and how
punishment might have started out as one
thing and then it comes to mean all
sorts of other things
that's what foucault is saying you know
institutions
by their very nature
develop all these other things you know
what we call mission creep takes place
right
um
all right so that's that's probably
enough about that chris interested in
your take
through a fukodian lens on how someone
on the right recently misinterpreted the
call for vaccination as max psychosis
and missed the generated paranoia of the
vaccine i'm not even sure what all that
means unfortunately
um miss the generated paranoia of the
vaccine that that's that doesn't uh
i'm having trouble figuring out what
those those words are supposed to mean
uh i mean a lot of people on the right
have misinterpreted calls for
vaccination for for a while
so
mass psychosis anybody can make any can
throw anything they want out there
about vaccine medical fascism is another
great example
i mean if you know anything about
fascism
asking people to get vaccinated
calling it medical fascism just strikes
me as like the ultimate pearl clutching
um
and and you know it sort of disqualifies
one from being able to have a reasonable
conversation
um
so i don't really know what what to say
about that i mean foucault would say you
know a lot of people
on the right are based you know they
have all this language about free
thinkers critical thinkers and all that
but they're really just being driven by
um algorithms that feed them garbage and
and hucksters and uh who may or may not
believe the the crap that they're
pandering um i mean if this was like
i've said this many times this was 30
years ago and we're back in a different
uh time politically
republicans and and democrats both of
them would have been for
handling this health crisis the way it
ought to be handled and it wouldn't have
been you know whether you wear a mask
whether you
uh take the the vaccine wouldn't have
been politicized the way the way it has
been but a lot of people made money or
careers or got to express their anger
about other stuff through doing that and
you know i don't think you need a
fukodian lens to do that it's pretty
straightforward georgia why does
centrist appear to be on the right
because typically you watch them long
enough and you know their their centrism
really is just you know they they don't
actually give both sides uh you know
a real take they
you have to look at the things that they
say and do over time to figure out that
they're just lying to themselves about
being independent they're not really
independent i mean
there may
i'll qualify that there may be a few
people out there who call themselves
centrists who actually turn out to be
that way but you always got to look at
them right and see what's going on
uh max how did foucault influence judith
butler's work on gender performativity
um
you know i don't know um i i don't know
her work
uh well enough
to be able to say here's where foucault
influenced this this and this and this
i would say that you know she's not
drawing extensively just on foucault
right but all sorts of
thinkers um the the notion that
um i mean here's here's where there
could be a connection so
performativity
why do people have to be
performative in their gender and all of
us have done this i mean i think butler
is on on to a lot of stuff and and
talking about that i'll give you a prime
example
the
um performativity of masculinity so that
other guys won't think that you're gay
when you're back in the 80s and being
gay
would be like uh you know a terrible
thing that would make you a social
pariah and
give license for all the other guys to
beat the crap out of you every single
day take your lunch push your face into
lockers all that kind of stuff
there were a lot of guys especially the
jocks who
i think were actually
um closeted
and had to pick on
some poor bastard
as as part of their performativity of
their masculinity to to be tough guys
and um
the secret was that they were actually
the ones who were gay um
no
that's that's performativity why would
they have to do that well can you think
about this in terms of power relations
i mean if you've got a
if you're a jock and you've got a coach
who himself is just a totally corrosive
influence like one of our coaches was
who ruined a lot of of young
men uh who he coached in football for
example um
terrible guy
there were power relations going on
right the position of coach to athlete
or to somebody in a gym class
there were power relations between all
of the different guys involved you know
sort of policing each other it was kind
of a rough time back in the 80s here in
the midwest
in terms of uh sexual politics and and
gender and stuff like that so
i mean that would just be one one
example of many
um
ricky asked how would a manual can't fit
into the current state of affairs i
don't know that a manual account would
fit into the current state of affairs
i'm not sure why why that's connected to
foucault
uh max how does heidegger influence
foucault's theory of power not much
um
i mean i i i don't see heidegger as much
of an influence on on fuco i think you
know one big influence on foucault
foucault doing the work of going to the
archives and seeing what's going on
nietzsche is certainly a bigger
influence than heidegger is on on
foucault um
a lot of these obscure uh uh
philosophers of science and french
literature are bigger influences on
foucault
than heidegger would be
zeno uh what book would you recommend to
someone new to foucault um how would you
introduce foucault to someone who hasn't
read them you got two two options there
one would be
to get
this
collected volume
set right
um
not a bad way to go uh you get
little bits and pieces
um there probably will be
a good bit of holy [ __ ] what the hell is
this crap experience this is funny
there's a little card in here
uh some stuff i was supposed to look up
all right so these these are decent but
i mean you could also say well i want to
begin
at the beginning do i have it
uh
you know
maybe start reading with madness and
civilization birth of the clinic right
um
i i don't think that there's one single
place that you have to go
actually there's do i have
uh
i thought i had a foucault reader here
but maybe i don't
um i got like a whole shelf of foucault
stuff
so you know
um
[Music]
all right
so i'm to skip some irrelevant stuff
here
um
anonymous says
am i familiar with esposito's immunitas
i don't even even know who esposito is
max how would you say foucault is
reacting marks okay so that's a that's a
really good question and actually
i wonder if i do have this still there's
a semi-text
yeah there it is
there's a semi-text book uh and this is
this is um
interviews right
um
so this is called uh
this wasn't my book originally this is
my friend gary mullins he lent it to me
i never gave it back
when you lend a book
don't expect to
to get the book back um
you know when i lend books i don't
expect to get back there is there is
this uh remarks on marx and that that
would be a good place to to start
um
foucault
like a lot of you know i mentioned like
derrida leotard duluz you know all these
guys
of his time and i would say you could
you could stick you know earlier guys
like lecon and bataille in there as well
they think there's something worth
getting out of marks but that the
marxists themselves often
obscure it mess it up
they're they're too doctrinaire about it
right
and
um
[Music]
so you can say that you know this is
actually kind of an interesting point
um
analysis of social conditions in terms
of classes that's something that anybody
can do you don't have to be a marxist to
do that here in america when somebody
does that they're like that's a marxist
analysis well no foucault things said
that you could do that too
you can't reduce everything to class the
way sometimes
you know kind of vulgar marxism does
um but class exists and class matters
and and class really does determine a
lot in in power relations so so there's
a lot there you you heard me talk about
um exploitation right foucault is
interested in economic uh activities
institutions how they develop
he he thinks that lots and lots of
people you know marx's marx's theory
about how capitalism takes surplus labor
gives it to the capitalists who then
reinvest it into the systems itself the
workers get poorer and poorer not only
do the workers get poorer and poorer
foucault would say the workers get more
and more controlled as well
um
[Music]
so you know
it's sort of a you could say it's not an
unqualified endorsement of marx
but you know there's there's uh
something there i think he also thinks
that
marxist regimes are typically going to
follow the same sort of trajectory of
power as as capitalist regimes
zeno's got another good question here um
is reading foucault's french difficult
i'm teaching myself french yeah
foucault's french is difficult
um
pretty much this is again a
generalization after like the 1950s
french writers
become way more difficult
if you read somebody like you know
maurice miliponti or
um
maurice blondell or ja or you know
jacques martinez be a good example
um
their writing is a lot more clear
in that earlier part of the century
and they remain clear
the the new
you know
the new kids uh on the block
they
they become part of this movement where
everything has to be made way more showy
and ornate and plays on words and crap
like that and that can get a little
precious
some of the time that said reading
foucault is not as bad as reading
derrida you know
even reading to lose is you know
especially if duluth is writing on his
own without qatari is not as bad as
reading derrida in that respect
um but it's just kind of what comes with
the
the the path and a lot of it is just
preciousness you know unfortunately so
in reading sartre
sark before you read foucault in french
because sarta is a lot more clear
as a writer his french is pretty pretty
straightforward
so
max has a good question here when
foucault says in relation to the history
of madness he's doing a history of
silence what does he mean by this trying
to resuscitate the you know what's been
silenced and what has been left out what
what has been overlooked what has been
um
shoved under but we have traces of and
we can recover um those and reconstitute
a
a story
about right
so that's that's important um
moises has an irrelevant question we're
talking about foucault here so
um
max says foucault engages with content
and what is enlightenment how does
foucault interact with
with kant
um you know foucault thinks that kant is
an important uh thinker on the way he's
got some interesting ideas
enlightenment doesn't turn out to be as
simple as as kant made it out to be
but you know kant was at a different
period when we could be a little bit
more
optimistic about like i mean if you
think about it what is enlightenment and
kant's project the moral project less
the epistemological project
is trying to do what foucault says we
can't have which is a society without
power
you know
um the kingdom of ends would be
you know one where human dignity is
completely respected foucault doesn't
think that's ever going to happen but
that doesn't mean we can't like work for
making it a bit better
devonnie how would you define foucault's
fala project uh what do you think he was
after in his philosophy many things you
know i i don't define people's projects
i don't define much of anything because
i think that definitions are something
we earn
rather than begin from as plato himself
said uh and aristotle echoed in in many
cases um
[Music]
i mean i think foucault was by himself
interested in the stuff that he was
working on and kind of fascinated by it
and he also wanted to like he said in in
the uh uh essay that i've i've quoted to
you several times here now subject in
power
um he wants to i mean why don't we just
read his words um
he wants to
do these analyses because he wants to
afford us
certain
possibilities
creating a history of the different
modes by which in our culture human
beings are made subject and and why why
do that well
because that allows him to
figure out where we could go from here
you know
so
um
[Music]
nl order of things really changed my
mind a lot really influential for my
historical project
yeah it's kind of funny because you know
foucault claims not to be a
structuralist but the order of things is
about as structural as to work as you
can possibly get you can even find him
without die diagramming it making the
gramacian semiotic square
so
um
okay so mark has a good question here
and this is what i'm going to go out on
because i do have to get to other work
today uh unfortunately before i i watch
the packers either win or lose
um could you please elaborate on
foucault's concept of powers between
subjects so this is this is a really
important point
foucault thinks
that power relations
are between
subjects people who have some degree of
agency people who maybe don't know know
themselves thoroughly or anything like
that but um
[Music]
certainly can have responses can take
responsibility for themselves and
when when relations are to the point
where you you make it so somebody
doesn't have any lines of possible
rejection or escape
it's no longer really power relations
you think it's it's sort of just
treating a person as a mechanical object
right
so
we
we we are subjects
and power relations are between subjects
foucault says that power relations are
where a subject acts
upon another subject's possibilities of
action so you know make them tells them
i want so let's consider a restaurant
right power relations exist in ordering
a drink the server comes to the table
and the server starts telling me about
the specials and i say no no no i don't
want to i don't want to hear about all
that crap go get me
a brandy old-fashioned that's a
particular drink here in wisconsin right
and then they're like oh oh okay let me
go off and do it
i've just
made them do something right is what we
would normally say foucault would say i
acted in such a way as to
try to steer them into a certain mode of
action now the the server could have
said shut up sir i'm going to tell you
the specials
there could have been consequences to
that but that was still a possibility
for them
instead they did something else um so
that i mean that that's that's a a
really
simple way of illustrating that and now
it can get much much larger you know we
can think about like how a form confines
our ability to to do something you know
we can think about this format that
we're in right here
and what we're confined to doing by
virtue of the
techniques of communication that it
makes possible for us which is something
that foucault
is interested
in so
all right so i
didn't answer everything but uh
you know irrelevant stuff we're not
going to answer in these these these
political things
um i already jad i already um
[Music]
uh
answered the thing about what to read
with foucault i don't think there's a
necessary reading before reading
foucault read foucault you know i'm
going to say that with every philosopher
you want to read hegel
read hagel you know you can you can look
at videos and
you know
read preparatory stuff if you want to
but sooner or later you got to make the
dive and actually read the person in
this case seneca all right so
um
all right so that's that's probably
enough for today and we'll do another
one next month i'm not sure what the
topic will be but we'll figure it out
then and uh thanks for all the questions
comments hopefully this uh
clarified some things about foucault
to end it complicated thinker lots of
stuff going on there don't don't buy
into any like sweeping assertions that
everything is power or it's all a prison
that's that's not foucault that's that's
somebody else making something out of
foucault
and um
yeah all right so i'll see all of you
down the line somewhere else